نعم حسن ما تزال الاوضاع على حالها من
الناحيه الميدانيه هنا في المنطقه
الجنوبيه من قطاع غزه حتى هذه اللحظه ما
تزال عمليات القصف المدفعي متواصله في
مناطق عده غربي خان يونس حيث العمليه
العسكريه التي تتركز في حي الامن و حي
الامل عفوا والمخيم الغربي وكذلك ايضا
منطقه بطن السمين الواقعه غربي خان يونس
عدا غارات جويه بين الحين والاخر تشهدها
المناطق الشرقيه كذلك المناطق الوسطى
والمناطق الشماليه الغربيه والمناطق
الجنوبيه الغربيه لخان يونس مع ارتفاع في
وتيره
ايضا القصف والاشتباكات المتزامنه مع هذه
الغارات عدا ارتفاع اعداد الضحايا بفعل
هذه الغارات المتواصله والقصف المدفعي في
هذه الاحياء البعض من هؤلاء الشهداء
ينقلون بصعوبه بالغه الى مجمع عناصر الطبي
في خانيونس وكذلك مشفى الامل المحاصر
المحاصر من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه عدا
ذلك هناك العشرات من الضحايا في الطرقات
خاصه في منطقه حي الامل ومنطقه المشروع
ومنطقه ايضا المعسكر الغربي حيث لم يستطع
احدا الوصول الى هؤلاء بفعل القصف
الاسرائيلي وتواجد الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في بعض في بعض الطرقات التي
تؤدي الى هذه المناطق التي قصفت في وقت
سابق من يوم امس ابرز هذه الغارات كانت
امام مدرسه قنديله التي تاوي عشرات الاف
النازحين في مخيم خانيونس وادت هذه الغاره
الى ارتقاء فلسطيني واصابه اخرين نقل الى
مجمع ناصر الطبي ايضا غاره على مجموعه من
المواطنين في منطقه جوره العقاد وغارات
اخرى بالقرب من مشفى الامل وداخل ساحه
مشفى الامل كان هناك ايضا اطلاق نار ادى
الى صبه خمسه من النازحين نقلوا الى
النقطه الطبيه على ساحل البحر غربي
خانيونس نظرا لخطوره حاله هؤلاء لان جزءا
كبيرا من عمل هذا المشفى قد تحول الى
النقطه الساحليه نظرا لاستمرار حصار
المشفى ليوم الثامن على التوالي واطلاق
النار صوب النازحين وكذلك ايضا نعم بحسب
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني مركبه اسعاف كانت
قد تعرضت لاطلاق نار من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه في ساعات مساء يوم امس عدا
اعمال التجريف المتواصله حتى هذه اللحظه
من قبل الجرافات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في
منطقه حي الامل ومنطقه ايضا المخيم الغربي
وحرق بعضا من المنازل بحسب ما افاد شهود
العيان وشاهدنا ايضا نسف م مربع سكني في
ساعات ظهر يوم امس في المنطقه الوسطى لخان
يونس جنوبي قطاع غزه هذا عن خانيونس كذلك
مدينه رفح جنوبي القطاع اما عن المنطقه
الوسطى فكان يعني مساء داميا بفعل غارات
طالت منزلين احداهما ل عاله المطوي ياوي
عشرات النازحين ادت هذه الغاره على الاقل
لارتقاء نحو 20 فلسطينيا عد المفقودين
ومنزلا لعال النابلسيه في منطقه مخيم
الصيرات وكذلك هناك سبعه من الشهداء نقلوا
الى مشفى شهداء الام الاقصى عد الغارات
التي كانت مكثفه في مدينه غزه في ساعات
ظهر ومساء امس الخميس وحتى انتصاف الليل
كانت الغارات متواصله على احياء تل الهواء
والزيتون والشيخ رضوان والنصر والتفاح
والدرج وكذلك الشاطئ ومناطق شمالي غربيه
غزه بالتزامن ايضا مع سماع صوات اطلاق نار
من قبل الرشاشات
الثقيله التي طبعا تتواجد في المناطق
الشرقيه الحدوديه وايضا اطلاق نار من
الدبابات الاسرائيليه في منطقه حي الزيتون
ومنطقه شكرا
لكات المح هاني الشاعر مراسل الجزيره
حدثنا من رفح